لنبدا بهذا الخبر من بريطانيا وهذه
الفضيحه الجديده التي تضاف الى ماتانكوك
وزير الصحه الاسبق في حكومه هذه المره
يواجه انتقادات واسعه بعد التسريبات مئه
الف رساله نشرتها صحيفه تيليجرام في
البريطانيه حول طريقه تعامله مع ازمه
جائحه كورونا ربما الرساله الاكثر
استفزازا لبريطانيين التي كشفت انه تعمد
بث الذعر خلال فتره كورونا قائلا اخافه
الناس هي التي ستحدث فرقا لكي يلتزموا
بالاجراءات الوقائيه وحسب المحادثات بين
حاول استغلال متحورات كورونا باسمائها
الجديده لتنفيذ خطه اخافه الناس الرسائل
المسربه تسلط الضوء على طريقه تعامل كبار
للمسهولين في بريطانيا بشان الفيروس بما
فيها فضيحه بارتي او حفله عيد ميلاد
اقامها جونسون ومسؤولون في مقر رئاسه
الوزراء خلال فتره الحجر المنزلي
يعني دائما مات هانكوك مثير للجدل فعلا
وحتى كمان الصوره الشهيره اللي تم تسريبها
لما كان يقبل مساعدته
وطريقه حميميه اثارت الجدل وحتى بفتره
كورونا